new rockstars assemble oh hey everyone
the title of Avengers forum may have
been revealed by the directors and a
very cryptic social media post and
because only the real Marvel news is
clawed out of social media posts we're
gonna break it all down for you
psychos and we're crazy as well guys
welcome to new rockstars news and what a
time to be alive this week we got a
trailer for Captain Marvel that we're
gonna talk more about and a first look
at Joaquin Phoenix as a joker a Loki and
Scarlet Witch dreaming series and a
Marvel themed comedy show that Tommy and
I are doing in LA no way that will get
to all that later I'm specifically not
but he's gonna be there yeah blacklisted
I'm Eric Bostrom at the table are filled
Malina and Tommy back told definitely
alright it was a concerted effort to
minimize the amount of banter that
happens in this section of the show
Thank You Tommy for immediately ruining
that yeah we this is a triple the amount
of average banter we normally have and
we don't apologize that's good let's get
start with our top story it's the
Avengers for title possibly being
revealed so here's what happened guys
the movies directors the Russo brothers
posted on social media set photo with
the caption look hard and he knows
Morrow fanboys are looking real hard at
this yeah now these directors know the
title of ventures forward is the big
detail that fans have been desperate for
the him to reveal Kevin Feige actually
has said in the past that the title
would come after the trailer for Captain
Marvel came out and that trailers now
here so give us give us a title title
time we're hungry for title it was a
freaking title ok so what are we looking
hard at here well it's a black and white
set photo of Joe Russo on the soundstage
for the movie possibly reviewing some
footage now some people have said that
these shapes of the letters with the
ladder and the equipment off on the
right looks like an A and an E yeah you
see that now in the past we have
speculated that should that affect cost
us just now 4.8 million
now to sound my teeth you didn't use
those teeth anyway banter the titles
like Avengers eternity right Avengers
eternal since the Russos did say
Avengers forever was not the title but
it was close and words like eternity and
eternal are also both names of Marvel
things right eternity is a cosmic entity
from the Infinity Gauntlet comics and
Eternals are the race of which Thanos is
a member always part eternal and his
grandfather Chronos master of time was
an eternal and also some people
speculated Avengers endgame referencing
Doctor Strange is lying to Iron Man and
infinity war and actually Tony Stark
said in game in each of Ultron's people
like it's all connected but then looking
hard at this image in a different way
some people have seen Joe Russo's
playback set up with the easel or
whatever that is as a second a shape
making them think it's two A's and
actually if you follow your eye over to
that machine off to the far left that
set piece actually showed up behind war
machine in Avengers HQ an infinity war
with some device that was in Tony
Stark's workshop you can see it yeah
it's the same as the same exact set
piece now some people have actually
pointed out that this chapter title on
the blu-ray release of the scene that it
takes place in is called Avengers
Assemble so maybe that's the clue that
we're looking at here what do you guys
think I think assemble is it's a little
late for that one it's kind of like
they're disassembled right now like yeah
very literally so I don't I like the
call out of that that item being there
maybe that's part of it they did say to
look closely and game feels feels good
to me yeah mostly I'm so frustrated that
I'm still like buying into these
trolling things that the reciprocating
the the title reveal at comic-con or
whenever was where they bleeped it out
and they can leapin it and they did that
that artwork recently or the Latian yeah
it was like the disappointment of being
Tommy something
yeah yeah you're only but I still feel
like I have no idea whether or not
they're actually teasing or they're just
being really mean to us yeah it'll be
like a big reveal right like they're
either jerks or they call time plus sign
on the back wall right yeah there was
some other stuff there looked like a
plus sign or an X maybe an A and a
teenagers x-men yeah Avengers trip which
would I mean like that would like make a
trillion dollars Adventures x-men
intersects but just yeah go ahead and go
for it I think what's he up there for
Tom maybe I have a little cameo wink
wink but you don't just say wink if
you're winking my any Tommy unfiltered
right now is robotic operations are
scared actually you mentioned Avengers
Assemble turns out that was the actual
name that the 2012 movie The Avengers
was marketed as in the UK something like
they've already used they've already
used in job got everyone in the UK
sweeps chimney simple I think was also
an animated film yeah it's not to say
they could just call this Avengers
symbol and then give the UK folks
another new name that for some reason
they would do yeah I don't see it being
a symbol I do think something like
eternal eternal or eternity would be my
guess cuz eternity even for people who
don't know what he turneth he is from
the Marvel Comics they're like oh but
that's still like this kind of forever
this never-ending thing it's a bit
redundant with infinity though but but I
think I could see that being the case I
mean one thing that I think we should
maybe you know step back from is this
idea of it beats and it's gonna be
mind-blowing because the Russo brothers
have I think said in interviews that
they like regret building it up so much
because I think when they reveal it it's
just gonna be like a simple word they
said that they only didn't want to
reveal it because of the mistake I think
it was Civil War is maybe the one that
that overshadowed the next Marvel movie
that was about to come out because
everybody you know had a title to talk
about a movie further down the road and
it's like why cares so much about an
in-between chapter if we already
the next step so the really so we just
want to tell you and now it definitely
became like you know it super brave
they're doing it in black and white
yeah yeah yeah very Logan oh yeah it's
an idiom a time-travel thing then
because the world was black and white
before the Year 1935 and look it up
people believe it yeah right
just they only had a black and white
paint it was the Wizard of Oz she jumped
ahead in the future halfway through the
movie and then those were my favorite
Doc's my favorite Doc's yeah you guys
need yeah we're really gonna show these
here well you know look they should have
released the title by now right we knew
what infinity war was years in advance
what do you holding out on we're not
it's not like phase four you don't have
to tell us what's gonna happen in phase
four just I tell it's a title of it I
want to do a little office pole ok pool
pool pool office pool party back in for
a pool table one of the favorite
episodes the Alps but other seasons but
when do we think it's gonna happen
toss a data whoever is the closest gets
something from Devon September 26 ok so
pretty soon twenty okay so terrible but
I'm fine with that so September 2016 20
it's is well I think it's gonna be is
Tuesday the 25th because I think it's
gonna be Tuesday I think they're gonna
wait a week after the Captain Marvel
trailer came out yeah 25 yeah yeah wait
you wanted to say Wednesday you a dollar
more just alright so then I'll say on
it's a Newsweek I'll say Monday
alright so whoever wins you guys can
tell us what we get yeah and I think a
question I want to leave you guys with
is what do we think that machine is do
we think that machine is important
because I think to me that's like the
biggest actual detail in this picture
like oh that was something like I didn't
yeah they I didn't I didn't pull it I
can't claim credit for it but you know
Devon Devon Devon
yeah it's pointing at me I am the
machine the no I think we've talked on
all different kinds of technologies that
could play a role in the Avengers for
barf for example Tony Stark's like his
hologram technology is that
emanates from or is this something some
kind of quantum tech that like allows
access through the technology that hank
pym has yeah I don't know if it'll be
important this seam just could take
place in that same Avengers a HQ or
maybe it's like after the aftermath of
it they store everything and storage and
and that's where they are now yeah do
you ever thought you did this table down
sometimes your gravity right I was just
thinking about that Thunderbolt Ross who
I meant to say I think could be a scroll
potentially no but accidentally said
Ebert Ross before and I lost all my cred
and I'm trying to why not you don't know
what he meant
no I meant Thunderbolt yeah why I'm
defending a hypothetical version any one
of us could be a scroll yeah some of us
are certainly a full and if you're
confused what this tweet means don't
worry Marvel co-president Louise
Esposito was equally confused by what
this was and he's a co-president of
Marvel if anyone knows what the title of
it is I wish fun role to be like I'm the
party adult maybe yeah alright well we
have a big announcement in case you guys
haven't heard yet new rockstars is
expanding beyond this YouTube channel to
a whole new platform we can watch us do
our thing really in the best possible
format it's called scene er and for the
first time ever you'll be able to watch
something with us while we break it down
so it's a Chrome extension that's really
easy to add so that when you stream
stuff on your computer you can open up
real-time video commentary from us and
we can point out interesting details
that you missed as they come up in the
movie or the TV show and that way we're
watching along with you rather than like
awkwardly retelling you what happened
the movie at you you know it's it's a
more of a collaborative process and it's
much more natural and you know not only
us talking scene or something you can
participate in as well senior lets you
give your take on the shows and movies
that you love to watch by synching your
reaction videos alongside what you're
watching in all in the same browser with
scenar you can create and share and
watch video commentary synchronized with
streaming shows movies and clips from
Netflix Hulu and YouTube so really
anything you want to watch on those
platforms sceners is available for
so just go to see nerd comm slash new
rock stars on your desktop computer and
watch with us and we have a new
rockstars channel and we actually just
put up a commentary breakdown I did on
Marvel's black panther and guys I felt
like I could go way more in depth with
this than I didn't on our YouTube
version and I could present my analysis
the way that I I deal II would want to
which is like we're rewatching the movie
together let's pause here look at this
it's something really interesting I
could take my time with it and I think
it's just something you guys will really
like seen her it's time to make a scene
check it out it's it's a plugin on
Chrome so yeah you got a jump on this
yes also we're working with a lot of
other youtubers on there too so if you
don't like us anymore
uh-huh maybe the people you do like are
on there but also a lot of like
up-and-coming comedians and stuff like
honestly everything is on there now or
will be on there soon but yeah and it
also as you guys have been giving some
great feedback on and I really
appreciate that too yeah alright well
check it out and we'll move on to this
week's trivia question oh boy oh boy
hold on to your butts yeah you ever seen
her channel your channel it's seen her
after dark
immediately make it so you can't our
trivia question this week is what was
the fake working title of Avengers the
2012 what working title did they use
their in production now these are the
fake titles that they do to like ward
off people from trying to steal reels
and footage and things like that alright
all of our answers are here in the
official answer bucket dynamite great
you still have the label on the bottom
yeah well you know I might want to
return it well this might not work out
later so reveal the answer to the trivia
question the closest has decided buyers
judge will do our signup goodbyes at the
end of video meanwhile the loser will
become the latest inductee into the gif
of shame but it's so much fun you're
hurting from laughing yeah let's move on
to some other news from this week last
week and we got our first look at the
Joker movie with set photos and some
footage too you know you can go check
out actually the video I did break it on
it down but even more recently Joker
director Todd Phillips released this
camera and makeup test of joaquin
phoenix as arthur flick let's take a
look
but I tried because young
as asked me by you took me by surprise
[Music]
okay yeah um I guess the laughing is
probably coming from Kevin Feige at all
the DC fanboys who are eating each other
alive and their online debates about
this um I don't know I I actually kind
of like this the song that you heard is
laughing by the guess who it's a
Canadian rock band from the 1670s pretty
great song now I would say it's not
totally clear if this is the make up
walking will actually where's the Joker
in the movie it is a makeup test they do
camera tests all the time in movies with
like still in development looks and
costumes of course most of them don't
get released until after the movie has
already been made but this video to me
looks a lot more produced than like just
a raw camera test like there's music and
camera movement editing and yeah for
sure it almost feels like a teaser even
though there's still they just
started production like two weeks ago
and there are some interesting choices
if you notice like look at his eyebrow
one of his eyebrows is like higher than
the other a good diamond Dover's oh yeah
and then he does a little thing when
Yuri watch every kind of that I
open so there's like some choices here
I'm curious what you guys thoughts are
on this alright this is making more or
less excited for this Joker movie so
legitimately I know I'm not super
excited about it I have issues with
Joker origin stories in general I do
like The Killing Joke I think The
Killing Joke was good but at the same
time it's like I don't know that I I'm I
want to actually see that play out in a
movie that said so I watched this and I
was like mmm
I just I felt myself like not letting
myself like it and then I reframed it
for a second and I realized like I know
Todd Phillips is from the The Hangover
and that's what we mostly know I'm from
but he you know he did was a war dogs I
think recently and like he's definitely
trying to branch out he's gonna try to
like prove that he's much more than just
this comedy guy he's working he's
writing the screenplay with another
screenwriter who did the fighter salute
like some interesting like dramatic
films as Christian Bale and and Mark
Wahlberg in that so then I sort of think
well you know what maybe they're not
telling like a story exactly about the
Joker that we know but rather as a story
of a deterioration of a good man who or
maybe a good man who wants like
entertain people and be good to people
then how he gets there and I think once
you start comparing that to like
Breaking Bad and better call Saul and
stories like that it's like damn
actually that could be really good as
long as I let myself kind of see it as
its own standalone yeah yeah I mean I
guess my question is does this need to
be a DC brand movie like right just
pitch me the story of like a struggling
comic eighties during the comedy to a
murderer who snaps you know it's your
story that's your origin story right no
you're not allowed to tell your lawyers
I forgot that's for the world that he
doesn't know that that's what he would
say I think like it's to me the only
thing that kind of takes me out of this
project because I think Joaquin Phoenix
is a great actor I think no I know I
think it's great I think everyone in the
cast sounds interesting to me it's just
this idea of like oh right this is
taking place in Gotham City Thomas Wayne
is this version of Thomas Wayne it's
like why not I mean I know it's hard to
just like do an original story and get a
green light by studio everyone wants
something that's based on like some
original intellectual property that has
like a bankable following but it's like
I don't know I I don't need for this to
be a DC movie I don't know if that will
take me out of it when I watch it it's
just a one drawback I have it's like how
people lately have been just like
talking about this I almost joke of an
idea but it's actually kind of cool
where they're like what if Batman was a
samurai what if we just saw that as a
good movie and it's kind of like these
like else world stories or everything it
would be cool to like have a movie
that's kind of like hey it doesn't make
sense with the other stuff who cares
right yeah let it be its own thing yeah
like it's hard to know going into the
movie that like there's no real hero for
this story mm-hmm he's gonna be the main
character his foil presumably is gonna
be a donald trump version of thomas
wayne has been screwed so it's like so
you're just not gonna like anyone by the
end well yeah by the end I would agree
but I bet he's the protagonist and that
he Polly has a clear goal and we're
kinda rooting for him and the fact that
he fails is maybe the interesting thing
you know you know he's gonna write but
also I mean you know the Godfather pulls
that off and in a certain way or saying
you know what I mean like
these are a night crawler movie where he
was like kind of a weird hums yeah night
crawler is actually a great example of
like someone who's like losing their
mind yeah no he wasn't my favorite guy
in that movie I just think like this
movie could suffer from a fatigue of
like there's gonna be venom which is
like the tagline of that is like there's
enough superheroes it's like if this
could be like the third in the line of
like right antihero yeah like how many
villains do we need to humanize
especially considering the art world
they finally make the penguin seem like
a man's man I people you you might be
joking but I legitimately I'm like
someone just do the penguin like not as
a joke Eggman
but name is Daniel but DeVito means
Eggman manovich but we'll you just said
did make me think like you know who is
the only one that kind of didn't feel
like it went with that and his solely an
example is Thanos right like Danis was a
clear villain and it didn't feel like
that tired thing of like oh we're
humanizing ability felt like this guy
has a thingy tragedy he's gonna do he's
gonna do anything it takes to do it yeah
we'll see I am excited about this story
just because I feel like you know DC
already tried doing something we're just
copying the Cinematic Universe model
like why not just like embrace what I
think is like what's great about DC
Comics is this kind of anthology take
like the characters just represent
themes and every time you can have an
ought to take it over you're gonna have
a Frank Miller coming and just say like
this is my view of it and I'm not gonna
betray who the character is I'm just
gonna like follow through and
extrapolate in one vector on what I
think Batman represents so if like I
think this could be a winning strategy
for DC especially yeah and why not take
a gamble on it it's apparently super low
budget it's like 160 million dollars
let's go make that yeah you've been
murdering billionaires and that's how
you have that money then
it's just real quick I'll say it is a
working strategy because it's working
for the DC animated films oh yeah I love
those movies and they're not
interrelated and they all take their own
different take on it it's great and you
know it worked for Logan to like this is
essentially like take a look the
difference is you have a new actor
taking over so there's always some
hesitancy when there's a new actor but
yeah I mean I think there is room in the
world for superhero standalone stories
that are not connected it's just it's
hard when the the norm is and the one
that's like changing the industry right
now is the cinematic universe model
right that's just one way to skin the
crew yeah but let us know what you think
about this and I gotta admit this is
really early to be seen such like we
aren't gonna see a Joker movie into like
probably 2020 our real late and 20
nights some people are tweeting that
they're like this isn't enough to react
to I'm like absolutely it is it's a
director put his after on camera set it
to music and yeah did it camera motions
that's a film yeah so the short teaser
yeah but then it might also be a good
sign that the the director has that much
confidence in what his vision is I do
think Todd Phillips is gonna try to
prove a point here yeah yeah I can't
wait till Zach Galifianakis shows up
with a baby okay everyone the biggest
news from this week was obviously the
new Captain Marvel trailer that
introduced us to brie Larson as Carol
Danvers and Captain Marvel she's you
know that's her this big new character
that's joining the MCU and gonna play a
major role in Avengers 4 we guesses on
90s Nick Fury and Phil Coulson and
Captain Marvel is you know smashing
blockbuster roofs and old lady jaws oh
boy
now we made a few other videos on this
channel breaking the trailer down but
one big mystery that remains is who
exactly is the villain of this movie we
know that one villain will be the scroll
headed up by Talos played by Ben
Mendelsohn he is a shapeshifter who is
infiltrated the ranks of shield and you
can actually see his human form briefly
in the trailer he's overseeing a scroll
autopsy I thought initially that might
be Coulson staying there but this
actually Talos and you know it's gonna
be awkward for Talos to watch right like
seeing one of your scroll brethren get
cut up on the table yeah well I mean his
son maybe they're establishing
motivation or something to make its
person or something yeah that's
like boyfriend the doctors like I would
just separate to the genitalia yeah hold
this now they are about like in
integrity and like they're warriors and
stuff too so this could be actually
pretty damaging to walk it'll be pretty
interesting
there's also Ronin of course he shows up
in this movie along with Korath from
guardians of the galaxy now we'll see
the backstory of these two creeks
streamis in this movie back when they're
still upstanding memories and members of
the Kree society but you know just
because they're good and this movie
doesn't mean they're like Boy Scouts
throughout throughout their life right
like I'm sure Hitler was still a dick in
art school so we'll see they might be
enemies in this movie too and the
character were theorizing about and this
is like to me the most interesting one
is Jude Law's character we assume that
he would be playing Marvel the Kree
warrior who in the comics passed on his
powers to Carol Danvers but the
filmmakers have yet refused to release
his character name calling him commander
of the Star Force and that's what I
called myself in high school and no one
knew my name either yeah so the theory
is that Jude Law could be playing jaan
raghav Ilyn in the comics recurring foe
to Captain Marvel and perhaps they're
introducing him in this movies like a
mentor figure who turns bad kind of like
Mordo and dr. strange and later in the
trailer you can actually see Carol
bracing to fight someone off-screen
and that could be Jude Law's character
but you know it also kind of looks like
the og shield black suit making me think
it's Talos what do the losses what do
you guys think is the most interesting
villain for Carol to take on in Captain
Marvel um personally I I'm still on the
Ben Mendelsohn telus side of things
because that to me okay so there's one
frustration there where if he can
shape-shift that's actually very
different from the version of him in the
comics where he's like the scrolled I
can't shape-shift so it makes him have
to be that much more vicious of a
warrior so that that part is like a
little off for me and I'm I want to see
how that plays out but the concept of I
mean shapeshifter villain is prot is one
of these like few things that I feel
like the MCU hasn't really done like
they don't like power villain right like
which is most of them that's a story
before
yeah that's why I don't think Ronin is
gonna be that much of a villain honestly
we've seen that fight and honestly it is
Josie yeah he's like a hammer closest to
shapeshifter we'd had is Loki who can
like pose as different people right but
in like in like that wasn't really the
point of Loki sure thing because Loki's
more you know treated as a god then like
a shapeshifter but specifically that
power of shape-shifting being used in a
manipulative way like a spy or something
that's pretty interesting to me yeah
yeah I mean one thing that I've touched
on in in the breakdown is this whole
comic backstory of operation galactic
storm I think the biggest threat in this
movie could be the Kree people
themselves we don't know a whole lot
about the Kree so far on the MC they're
showing up in agents of shield and other
than Ronan in court that's it's pretty
much it we know that there's they're a
relatively peaceful Society or maybe
really but they've denounced the
extremeness like like diplomatic peace
absolutely they've been kind of jerks
and agents of shield they just like they
only care about their own race and they
just like beat up everyone and they also
have an understanding that like humans
don't about like galactic importance and
whatnot like they're objectively way
more important than than humankind uh at
least to them but also yeah you're right
it they just look like jerks so part of
me feels like they have to give them a
nice portrayal in this otherwise I mean
it's like if like humankind was
represented by like OJ Simpson and
Charles Manson it's like Oh humans are
kind of I think the it is a good point
unless like Kevin Feige never intends to
bring the Kree into the MCU other than
this moment like maybe he's just been
setting them up as he's like kind of
military force who is or was in a war
with the Skrull and maybe this could be
like another opportunity to do what they
do didn't Winter Soldier and kind of
point out this like military corruption
of bureaucracy like what if you had this
military society that was too much in
the military industrial complex and was
willing to do horrible things to their
own people it's kind what happens in the
galactic storm economic scene well on
the scroll are kind of like that too so
yeah you're right it kind of reminds me
of like Star Trek races or whatever
works like a choice of what whether or
not they want to portray the Romulans or
whatever like that way like are we gonna
actually build up the the Remus versus
drama or kind of like it's a bad guy
it's Eric Bana or something you know
like like they could go either way I'm
pretty down with them like setting up
you know like potentially a crease
Crowell movie or something yeah yeah I
would be interested to find out why
exactly carol danvers comes back to
earth like if she's a member of this
elite team in space
what causes her is an accident by which
she comes back or is it a choice to be
like I don't want to be part of this
life anymore and I wen identify myself
with earth and if that's the case
where's she been all this time has she
been into the did she go back and she's
trying to take the fight to them to make
sure that you know they don't come to
earth and get them wrapped up in some
collateral salty earth damage you know
is that I still like the idea that she
was banished or something some sort of
thing like that and that's why she
doesn't remember someone wiped her mind
intentionally yeah yeah shot in the dark
Howard the Duck is related to Talos he
plays with them somehow I feel like
they're gonna like all that back at some
point yeah he's got to come back right
yeah all right another quick update from
this week guys was announced that Loki
and Scarlet Witch will get their own
spin-off series on Disney's upcoming
streaming service playing to come out
the service is gonna come out in late
2019 and Tom Hiddleston and elizabeth
Olsen will reportedly play their parts
in this they're gonna recast it just
fascinating
now this streaming service will be
Disney's attempt to compete with Netflix
of course it will most likely have
exclusive rights to everything Marvel
Star Wars Pixar Disney Animation and
soon of course all of Fox's film and TV
properties will be all under one
umbrella the service will also roll out
other news series like a Star Wars
series from Jon Favreau so thing I have
original content it's gonna be like
their own Netflix set it's gonna be a
huge like soda Wars all over again but
streaming Wars now the big difference
between this Loki Scarlet Witch show and
other Marvel TV shows like agents of
shield and all the daredevil Netflix
shows this one will actually produced be
produced by Marvel Studios not Marvel TV
so Kevin Feige will have a lot more of a
role he's made very hands-on with
developing this it's gonna feel a lot
more like the movies rather than just
like occasionally referencing things
that have happened in the MCU but to me
the obvious question is here how the
hell is this possible
right these two characters died in
infinity war and not only that they died
in different ways so you have the
dusties and you have the people who
saw-like have heart failure and lose
their pulse like Scarlet Witch we get it
you know she does dit maybe her soul
just went somewhere else we don't really
know what happened there
but we saw his next snap we heard it his
he kind of like cross-eyed right we have
done a couple videos on Loki's not
really dead I don't watch your Bigfoot
thank you for calling a Content yeah
there's a no I I'm curious to see what
happens I think really should we not
take any of the deaths in infinity were
seriously at this course not I mean of
course at the same time it could be a
prequel right it could be set in the 90s
Seattle grunge scene or something
because they both look that way but I
feel like it's not gonna be a prequel
but like the kid they always have that
answer it's like oh it's before right
we're running into an issue with with
the what was at first
Piderman - oh yeah our motion for it's
like well maybe it's a prequel like that
answer just exists so I guess but ya
know everybody's coming back yeah coming
back for me I'm like The Scarlet Witch
TV show seems interesting I don't need a
low-key TV because it kind of is what
the movies have been that they've been
like Loki's story like multiple chapters
of Loki as Loki and I would love for him
to come back and be in yes I just
it feels unnecessary to do a whole TV
like is he gonna be there's gonna be
seven seasons of a Loki TV show yeah
trying to find redemption and solving
crimes in the Midwest I do like the
Scarlet Witch thing too because I last
week I said that they nerfed her like
she's such an interesting character and
kid is capable of so much and instead
she does like chief such as like Jubilee
powers basically in the MC there's got
to be the most awkward to shoot with the
effects do because like her entire job
is to go like this with their hands just
like imagine there's power is coming
yeah imagine you're like a baby painting
on this portrait oucampus i mama put out
I wanna ask you guys actually I do you
think this is like just like a dick move
or it's like Netflix did not get to even
like make too many references to the
Avengers with their movies and then here
they're like a will have them star in
our show
yeah yeah that's how they call like they
called the attack on New York and the
first season of daredevil they like you
know when New York went down yeah that
big green guy so when they referenced
Captain America lieutenant North
America's back that's my secret I think
I don't know if it's it's a slap in the
face I think it's kind of like weirdly
studio corporate rivalry cuz isn't a
Marvel TV underneath like poem pull my
pole Perlmutter yeah and that he's in
charge of like toys and TV and a lot of
the stuff and Mikey's like we're doing
our own thing over here Marvel Studios
and we can do content control here look
at your portrayal of Kevin Feige is
always that he's like just the most
cocky yeah Knicks most powerful man in
show business as they ranked this way in
the world
King this world Kevin yeah I am and who
knows what will happen maybe the the
rights to if this Disney streaming
device service takes over those Marvel
Netflix shows may be moved back over I
don't know if who knows what happened
it's gonna be a big name tree it's
definitely gonna take over it's got this
and Star Wars and Pixar potentially I do
like shows and all the Fox's stuff but
we're talking about like all the
Simpsons an avatar Deadpool x-men
original so yeah we'll see what happens
here and it's just crazy that we can
announce a Loki Scarlet Witch streaming
series but not the title of the movie
that's coming out in six months but
that's just my grape another quick
update this week Disney CEO Bob Iger
list section is number one most powerful
person in the world and in the world
said that Marvel had Kevin Feige number
six will complete control over well
he'll get complete control over the
x-men and Deadpool when they rejoin the
Marvel brand Eiger said it only makes
sense for Marvel to be supervised by one
entity it's funny that he called a
person an entity and there shouldn't be
two more goals is what he said
chemically under the eternal
wouldn't rule out that Deadpool could
become an Avenger that's something like
that also I should say in the same
conference Eiger confirmed that the
studio does plan for a slowdown on Star
Wars movies after episode 9 he said that
he took the blame for rushing out to
many star wars movies too fast in the
past couple years and but they still
plan on these other projects at the
developing Benioff and Weiss from Game
of Thrones are developing his Star Wars
saga of their own but he doesn't intend
to rush anything in the future
so what'd you guys think about this with
Feige overseen a possible Deadpool and I
mean amazing that's like what we've
always wanted and what i've been
screaming at my parents for for years
but i might one of my takeaways about
the way he was talking about the whole
thing is actually like he didn't really
make it sound like they needed to reboot
everything like i still think they will
but you know you would think that he
would have said like you know Feige
deserves his own interpretation of these
characters and like he kind of wasn't
saying that kind of stuff i think cuz
they are in that situation where it's
like well Deadpool
it should not be redone and recast maybe
the x-men should and were like but then
also the Hugh Jackman portrait like
there are they are in a very tough spot
about what they should reboot and what
they shouldn't so I think he's dancing
around that but it makes me wonder like
are they gonna maybe actually try to
work with these people yeah we'll see I
mean I in a lot of ways is a homecoming
right Kevin Feige got into the superhero
gig he was one of the original producers
on the first x-men movie with Hugh
Jackman and Halle Berry that original
like 2000 movie and that was like to me
it feels like the start of it all well
yeah what started this new trend of like
modern superhero movies that are trying
to like build these franchises and build
movies that can connect to each other as
opposed to like when Tim Burton was
doing movies in the house yeah or
Richard Donner was doing super in movies
it didn't feel like they're trying to
build like a new brand as much so Feige
does know the x-men like this is his
baby in a way that's kind of babies
coming home so it's kind of nice to see
but yeah one more update this week we
learned that daredevil season 3 will
drop on Netflix on October 19th and we
got another announcement video plus it's
cool-looking poster and won't we have
this up just want to point out a couple
of fun details here if you look closely
you can barely make out
the Avengers Tower it's included in the
New York skyline there
see they Brett rates at the same same
world same universe it's Avengers tower
sir the other show has the leads of the
Avengers you know if you look closely
the design is gonna get fired
referencing the Batman comic if you guys
seen that oh where you look closely you
can see circumcised yeah yeah also one
of the movies looks like a unicorn
remember that poster Dark Knight Rises
looks like a unicorn you can't unsee it
looks like a unicorn we're putting it up
in post there it is see looks like you
and you guys grew that's definitely a
christ pose there right there's some
born-again imagery with the daredevil
comics that season 3 seems to be
inspired by so if you love the morning
economic yet
Tommy Christ guys now it comes time for
our new rock search news lightning round
yes soaking wet so damn I'm gonna fire
them at my co-host they got answer these
as quickly without hesitation is
possibly ready I'm ready doesn't matter
Tommy and Amelia or at a what's to know
or Amelia irate do you think the Hulk
would melt for kittens like he's in full
Hulk smash mode and then see some
kittens in peril or maybe puppies what
does it take to melt the Hulk's hurt a
lot of heat baby I think the kittens are
gonna end up being pulverized if the
hogs in all I think we're getting hit in
puree I think the only way the Hulk's
heart is you know stiff drink a lot of
eye contact and some smooth jazz all
right yeah speaking from experience the
house disturbed by gas prices are you
doing your homework incredulous Philip
add to one fj CEO if wants to know if
Hugh Jackman agrees to play Wolverine in
the MCU with the caveat that all the
movies he stars in our musicals would
you be on board for that
marvel make a musical MCU work uh no but
I am super down actually for a Marvel
musical you just got to do it the way
that Harry Potter did it did it
they put a play on Broadway put a MCU
musical on Broadway and I would go see
it Hugh Jackman is delightful he
probably wouldn't star in that he's way
too big but there's plenty of people
that could play that role III know this
is kind of a joke question but if I see
Jeremy Jordan as Hugh Jackman's version
of Wolverine on stage I will buy a
ticket in there will fly there like the
spider-man turn off the dark was a huge
hit right and what come watch me sing
about Marvel but stand over your plug
I'm in my own alright
[Music]
there's three options to hit the one in
the middle
rocky okay Eric from at underscore yeah
Mazda underscore if you had to open a
small note here mastico which means you
called you called if you had to open a
small business with an MCU villain who
would it be and what would your business
be called hashtag nailed it shaking it
with a question or it says hashtag now
it is a good question let's see how
about thighs with feyo's oh it's just
like it's like a workout regimen and
it's a business that you buy exclusive
organized yeah you get thick you should
be thrown business that's pretty good
men weed exotic read just install your
lightning round question - no I'm not
being pimped out like this
okay well now comes the time for a
15-second shout out where I'm gonna pimp
out Phillip - 15 seconds - shout out
blocker we have about anything
Phillip go for it okay easy register to
vote make sure you make sure you are
registered if you're unsure - super easy
to like re register I'll throw up a link
on my Twitter and I'll just like pin it
or remember but it's super easy so make
sure you're registered to vote election
is pretty close yeah and even if you
think you're registered you might not be
register twice you can go twice tummy
space GM 2 is coming out it's gonna be
produced by Ryan Coogler it is yes yeah
I'm very excited about that
I excited to see who the new Monstars
are gonna be because it was like Muggsy
Bogues Sean Bradley um shortest and
tallest guy which now I think they said
be Isaiah Thomas and the other is a
Thomas and forget her the tallest guy in
the NBA is now but he'll be very
exciting to see who the new monsters
I'm excited for Space Jam - is my shadow
yeah for my shoutout once again I know
I've talked about this in a couple
videos if you live in the LA area check
out infinity fan it's a next Sunday or
next Saturday September 29th at the Acme
theatre in North Hollywood it's gonna be
real fun Tommy and I are and it Philips
helping out in other ways he doesn't
know yet okay I got asking for some
favors after we take this it's a parody
sketch show musical of everything we
talk about on this channel and I've been
like working nonstop on it and I'm super
nervous about but very very excited and
and this is just like your chance to
come watch us do something else but also
like meet us afterwards like we'll be
there talk to us yeah but yeah I think
you'll really enjoy it and I really
wrote the show with like you guys have
in mind specifically I read the comments
I see your tweets I'm like you know
there needs to be a show just for these
guys with my shout out and and yeah and
if it is you ask me we can record it I
would but I can't I might want to do it
again so I don't want to just like you
know give the milk away for free right
so I got on film yeah well you're a
Native American on your credit skills
your soul vampire let's return to the
trivia question that we asked earlier
and reminder that our punishment will be
the gift of shame shame so yeah as
always the wrong in stance about to draw
a task from the gift of shame container
and they have to perform that task
repeatedly while the winner reads the
goodbyes and the other one of us will
challenge shame at you and stupidity
will be turned into an animated gif
which will blast out on social media to
punish you for your trivia ignorance you
fool you beautiful beautiful let's
remind us of what the question is what
fake working title did the Avengers in
the year 2012 used during production
okay so let's see what we wrote
I have Erik and the also wrote Erik
and he said always angry yeah angry
female wrote Brotherhood always angry
alright Ike I'm having trouble figuring
out which side is which I let's say the
muscle honk no way oh look at Big Daddy
T the - ok that's ok confirmed
Rojo muscle hunk meet up 99 for the year
1999 I presume but the movie came out in
2012 or there were 98 are there muscle
Haim comedic movie they're all they're
all winners or the correct answer was
group hug ah
group hug hug yeah okay Devin go wrong
in group hug yeah that's yeah that's
good and up me and Tommy who's the wrong
guess I was always angry said muscle
hunk is definitely muscle hunk is all of
the Avengers which is the muscle sweet
babies in their hot guy who literally is
just a good aim and he's got ripped
wraps ripped trash rips trap yes well
that's just mad at you finally okay so
I'm gonna drop them the gift of shame
here and then I have to like do this
task over and over again like repeat it
and it'll be turned into a gif and I'm
real nervous about it so pretend there's
a little fairy that only you can see
floating in front of your face endlessly
farting ah pretend Sam's here that's
really dark mod shame shame shame hey
Eric what's going on are you talking to
you all right I'm okay you're supposed
to be reading the goodbyes shame shame
all right guys thank you so much for
watching this episode of new writers
news I want to thank our host
Tommy Bechtel it down at the end you can
hit him up at Tommy Beck told me I am
Phil Malina you gave me up at fimo and
then who are you talking to her a TA
boss you can hit him up also make sure
to check out their comedy show make sure
to comment down below whatever theory
you have about some we talked about or
who's gonna win that pool thing we did
earlier I tweeted us at new rock stars
like this video share it around
subscribe to us here but also at senior
calm slash rock stars we will all see
you next week
don't see anything no this is my CD
he took your gif of shame if I see him
two months like no one agrees with that